الى باكستان حيث تقدم رئيس الوزراء السابق
وزعيم حزب انصاف عمران خان بالتماس امام
محكمه لاهورد ضد مذكره اعتقاله بتهمه
بتهمه تتعلق بمخالفات قانونيه وفي السماء
بعد امرت المحكمه جهاز الشرطه بتعليق
تنفيذ امر جلب خان قبل مثوله امام محكمه
ابتدائيه في العاصمه غدا السبت معنى الان
من امام المحكمه العليا في لاهور مراسل بل
مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد الرحمن مطر
ليوافينا بالتطورات
منذ تقريبا ساعه ونصف ازدهار ورئيس
الحكومه الباكستانيه السابق عمران خان
موجود داخل قاعه المحكمه الرئيسيه هنا في
محكمه لاهورا العليا يحاول مع فريق الدفاع
المكون حقيقه من عدد كبير من المحامين
اقناع القاضي بالحصول على ما يسمى
بالحمايه القضائيه وذلك للحيلوله دون ان
يتم اعتقال عمران خان عندما يتنقل غدا من
هنا من لاهور الى العاصمه حيث يتعين عليه
ان يمثل امام قاضي محكمه ابتدائيه للنظر
في قضيه تتعلق بانه اساء التصرف في عدد من
الهدايا الباهظه الثمن التي تلقاها من عدد
من رؤساء الدول عندما كان رئيسا للحكومه
الباكستانيه
محكمه اسلام اباد العليا كانت بدورها قد
منحت عمران خان نوع من انواع
التعاطف ان صح التعبير لا سمعوا انها امرت
الشرطه بعد اعتقال خان عندما يتنقل من
لاهور الى الاسلام لكن فريق الدفاع عن خان
مصر على ان يحصل من هنا من محكمه لهون
العليا ايضا على حمايه قضائيه الحديث عن
عشر محاضر تم فتحها لدى الشرطه هنا في
لاهور وهناك خشيه من ان يتم اعتقال عمران
خان في اي من تلك المحاضر العشر اضافه
بالتاكيد لامر اعتقاله فيما يتعلق بجلبه
الى المحكمه في اسلام اباد للنظر في قضيه
الهدايا بهذا الثمن الكثير من التعقيد
القانوني هنا الكثير من من القضايا على
الاقل 36 قضيه يتم النظر فيها في عدد من
المحاكم في هذه القضيه لوحدها الان هناك
ثلاث محاكم في باكستان معنيه بها محكمه
العليا محكمه العليا اضافه بالتاكيد
للمحكمه الابتدائيه في استعمال حيث يتم
تسجيل القضيه
وسيبدا النظر فيها يوم غد الكثير من
الاجواء هنا مئات من
المحامين وعدد كبير من الصحفيين وعدد كبير
جدا ايضا من الشرطه مكافحه الشغب تحديدا
الذين تم الدفع بهم الى هنا للحيلوله دون
ان يتم او يقع اي نوع من انواع المصادمه
ان صح التعبير بين انصار خانه الذين وصلوا
الى هنا باعداد كبيره وكل هذه
الجزيره كنت معنا من لاهور شكرا جزيلا